رفض قادة ثلاث
منظمات حكومية مختلفة مكلفة
بحماية الرئيس أو
الأماكن التي يقضي فيها
وقته الدعوات
الطوعية للاستجواب من قبل مكتب المدعي العام الذي
يقود التحقيق في
اغتيال الرئيس جونز مويس
أحد هؤلاء الرجال الثلاثة ديمتري يخطئ
يقود وحدة
مكلفة بحماية المقر الرئاسي
، وتمكنا من التحدث
إلى صديق مقرب من القضبان
يقول إنه بريء
وأن أي شكوك حوله هي
ببساطة دوافع سياسية ، إليك جزء
صغير
من حديثنا الذي يُقتل الرئيس
على ديمتري  شاهد لماذا لا يكون
مشتبهاً به
أنا لا أقول أنه يجب أن يكون
مشتبهاً به ولكن
الشيء الرئيسي هو أنه يجب
استجوابه
ومشتبه به محتمل نعم لكن
سلسلة القيادة لا تتوقف عند
ديميتري
هذا هو  التسلسل القيادي هو أعلى
بكثير منه ،
فهناك رؤساء وهؤلاء الرؤساء لديهم
رؤساء ،
آه لا أرى أيًا منهم  إذا كنت تعرف أنه تم
طردك من العمل
أو استجوابك أو
تم احتجازه ، فهو الشخص الوحيد
حتى الآن الذي يتم احتجازه ، لذلك
بعد رفض هؤلاء الرجال الثلاثة
استجوابهم ، ليس من الواضح بالضبط إلى أين
سيذهب مكتب المدعي العام بعد ذلك
وما الذي سيأتي بعد ذلك.
من الواضح أن التحقيق
في اغتيال الرئيس جونز
مويس بعيد كل البعد عن الأنهار
المطلقة.